Texan star defensive end JJ Watt wanted
to weigh in on what's going on with
family Friday
oh hey JJ how are you dan good 65 290
okay I am I've been loving it I'm not
gonna lie to you I've been loving to
meet Friday songs it's been the quality
of production is so high it's been
extremely intriguing to listen to it do
you have a favorite meet Friday song
well I had a I'm obviously from
Wisconsin I live in Texas now so John
and Wisconsin was up there and then I
believe I'm not 100% sure but I think
the too sexy for my shirt I think that
one was from Houston and I think it got
bumped but I thought that one was
phenomenal and then I mean regulators is
obviously the number one seed by a
pretty clear margin do you work out to
the meet Friday songs or is that
something maybe just special times
separate time when you're alone in your
car yeah no I can't handle the meat
sweats during my workout it's just a
peaceful time on my drive home just
nothing like putting on a good me Friday
song to listen to our way home scene
could you give JJ Watt some trig you
laters regulators at regulating any
grilling on this barbecue it's damn good
too which can't be any
got to be careful with the veal if you
know what I mean check the heat later it
was a clear Friday right around noon DP
and the boys were trying to consume I
can just see you driving home from a
workout got your gangster lean on and
you're listening to trig you laters I
mean they're so good like that's the
thing that blows my mind is just the
quality and clearly the time that people
put into this I love it I think it's so
cool that people are that invested from
hot dogs and North West so juicy it's
can you can you believe that I get paid
to do this with stuff like this why
would I stop I mean it meant having fun
it's great do you have any musical
talent like could juice maybe submit and
meet Friday song for next year no okay
no I wish I did that's one I always
wished I could play the guitar I thought
that'd be cool or something but no not
how's the offseason by the way good it's
going really good yeah I'm enjoying it's
really my first healthy water in a
couple of years it's been really nice to
just train and feel normal
do players want more replay I would say
they just want the call right I mean
that's I mean that's all and I mean I
don't know I haven't really dove into
how it all is gonna work now but I mean
I imagine it's probably just the same
amount of challenges just more stuff you
can challenge so it's not like it's
gonna slow the game down at all but I
was wondering about there's no you know
reviewable calls for roughing the passer
but we do have it for pass interference
like you know that Dee Ford hit to
Brady's helmet which shouldn't have been
called roughing the passer should those
calls be reviewable as well I mean that
was a huge call in that playoff game
yeah I mean I'm obviously I'm you know
my position on that
brother got a sign for last year that
was touchy at best yeah but it's you
know it all depends on what you open it
up to like you said I think earlier in
the show if you open it up to everything
then you can find something on every
single planet yes I mean if you open it
up to holding but yeah I mean I'm gonna
go to my coach and say throw the flag on
every play you know so it just it all
depends on what you want to I think that
they're going more towards making the
calls on the field as right as possible
which is good for both the fans and the
players I would imagine good to have you
call in check in and you know this is
gonna get pretty intense with the the
meet Fridays we head to the final fork
and then we crown our national
championship yeah I don't know how it's
going to play out it's it's getting
really tight in the races so I'm looking
forward to it I'm glad that I don't have
to do the deciding the fans do it so I'm
just enjoying listen I thank you guys
for the entertainment Thank You JJ good
to talk to you enjoy the rest of the
offseason have a good one guys
that's jayjay wanted the Texans for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]